[Music]
Chris you were hilarious and this is 40
hilarious in the movie well thank you
that's very nice and you I know you're
you're you're busy doing press I think
you've been doing press with Megan Fox
so you're in this scene with is that
right now we uh yeah we've been doing
the junket thing which has been fun but
when you're doing like when you're being
interviewed by E or whatever it is with
Megan who's just out of baby nobody
cares what you really have to say so
they're they just want to know how she
got her body back yeah yes so all
they're all those people just wanted
that kind of media just wants to know
about Megan's yeah post baby body and I
found that my role increasingly over the
course of the interviews was to make up
fake secrets how to get your body back
so they would be like howdy how did you
do it Megan and I would just say Catlett
or juice broccoli belly rub so now all I
need to do is I buy the domain name for
broccoli belly rub and I'm gonna be a
millionaire's now sounds like a pretty
terrible idea now you had a in the movie
you have a scene it takes place right
next to the scene we just saw where
you're actually in the pool with Megan
you're in a bathing suit she's in a
bathing suit looking fantastic were you
nervous shooting that scene I mean she's
so other notif one in otherworldly way I
was I guess I was I was worried more
than anything that like my masculinity
would overpower the scene
I don't know how to put it I I was I
didn't want her or any of the crew to be
afraid so I very kind of you to worry
about other well I've been there I've
been there and I can see the eyes kind
of the dilation the dilation of the of
the pupils not like pupils in a school
this was just in a normal adult scenario
I understand so I wore no endless before
you presume though no one did
no one did Chris so I decided to wear
just like the tightest
that ties us to tire I could find this
bathing suit yes yeah to hold things
down like like like freeze dried
apricots hold it all hold it all hold it
all in yeah and I think it worked
yeah it worked it looked in on
impressive you are you are we have a
kind of a similar build you know we have
a sort of a similar builder if you
struggle with some of the same issues
that I struggle with you know in terms
of how my body is presented yes I have a
big torso
this is an issue that I've had so in a
lot of I don't I don't get to do nude
scenes a lot I'm actively discouraged
yeah from any nudity like in the nature
of the work that I do sometimes you know
organically clothes will come off or
whatever will happen in this scene and
that is when the director's cut no we
don't want that we don't want to
I would like to do a lot more nude
scenes but that people seem really on
him uninterested yeah that's okay and
also because we are both pale yes
there's you know you can see the light
on people's faces just beaming off our
Irish bodies yes that's what I know what
you're talking about
yeah so I find that tricky and also
because we're tall and I don't want to
go into though it's like putting a
bicycle against the limousine you know
because the torso is so big everything
else looks pretty miniscule I don't know
what you're I don't know I don't just
like I don't know what you're talking
about